in the last 48 hours there have been a
flurry of Articles and interviews
revealing key details about our march to
artificial general intelligence I'm
going to extract out the most
interesting parts and Link them to a
series of other recent developments and
if there's one theme it's that the AGI
these companies are creating is not just
a clever chatbot and is coming much
sooner than you might think if AI is a
lot more than just a clever personal
assistant what actually is it well let's
turn to this bombshell article in wired
they say open AI doesn't claim to know
what AGI really is the determination
would come from the board but it's not
clear how the board would Define it Sam
mman who is on the board of open AI said
I would happily tell you but I like to
keep confidential conversations private
and then said but we don't know what
it's going to be like at that point not
being able to Define AGI continues on
their website where they first say that
AGI is AI systems that are generally
smart smarter than humans but elsewhere
they say their definition of AGI is
highly autonomous systems that
outperform humans at most economically
valuable work and back to the just
relased article it seems that confusion
continues with Microsoft it says
Microsoft wasn't even bothered by the
Clause that demands reconsideration if
open AI achieves AGI whatever that is at
that point says nadela the CEO of
Microsoft all bets are off it might be
the last invention of humanity he notes
so we might have bigger issues to
consider once machines are smarter than
we are open AI even have a legal
disclaimer that says you as an investor
stand to lose all of your money we are
not here to make your return we're here
to achieve a technical Mission oh and by
the way we don't really know what role
money will play in a post AGI World in
their restructuring documents they have
a clause to the effect that if the
company does manage to create AGI all
Financial Arrangements will be
reconsidered but not clearly def finding
AGI seems to play into the hands of
Microsoft who can always say well we
haven't reached it yet I don't think
Microsoft is going to lightly allow all
of their trillion doll Financial
arrangements to be reconsidered and
again we have this the company's
financial documents stipulate a kind of
exit contingency for when AI wipes away
our whole economic system but then
apparently the company's leadership says
this it would be hard they say to work
open aai if the individual didn't
believe that AGI was truly coming and
furthermore that its arrival would mark
one of the greatest moments in human
history why would a non-believer want to
work here they wondered three more quick
insights from wired before we move on
first that samman was planning to run
for governor of California before he
planned to build AGI second that in a
2015 interview with the same journalist
at wired samman was a bit more clear
about what he thought the job impacts of
AGI would be he predicted the challenge
of massive Automation and job
elimination that's going to happen this
chimes in with a quote from the new book
The Coming wave that I got Early Access
to written by Mustafa sullon the head of
another AGI lab he said these tools are
only temporarily augmenting human
intelligence but they are fundamentally
labor replacing and finally from wired
was this quote that I found really
interesting samman's original Vision was
not to make a single entity that is a
million times more powerful than any
human he wanted lots of little AIS not
one super intelligent AI but samman is
now talking about making a super
intelligence within the next 10 years
that's as productive as one of today's
largest corporations which don't forget
have millions of human employees this
fits in with his view that AGI is only
going to get built exactly once once
you've got it you could then use it to
build everything else and if you think
the the timeline of within the next 10
years sounds wild wait till you hear
some of the quotes towards the end of
the video and the key thing to remember
is that it's not about models just
getting more smart it's about them being
more capable more able to match a goal
with a set of actions as the chief
scientist at open AI Leah sukova said
the upshot is eventually AI systems will
become very very very capable and
Powerful we will not be able to
understand them they'll be much smarter
than us notice the words capable and
Powerful there and his vision by the way
is that we imprint on them like a parent
to a child so that they eventually feel
towards us the way we feel towards our
babies now I don't know about you but
it's challenging for me to imagine the
human race as a baby in the arms of an
AGI or super intelligence but some of
you may be thinking is a super
intelligence just a really smart chatbot
that sits on a web page somewhere well
no for many reasons starting with the
fact that we're we're building autonomy
into them I've already discussed on the
channel how open AI are working on
autonomy and here's Google deepmind
recruiting for the same purpose and what
kind of tasks are we talking about what
about commissioning from a factory the
purpose of the modern sharing test is to
measure what an AI can do not what it
can say capabilities practical creation
of real things in the real world or the
use of digital tools invent a new
product from scratch to get that
manufactured by commissioning it in a
factory negotiate over the the
blueprints of the product actually get
it drop shipped and sell the the new
product his company inflection AI want
their Pi personal intelligence to be
your digital Chief of Staff booking
flights bargaining with other AIS and
maybe even making a million dollars this
is particularly interesting to me
because sullon says that they are not
working on autonomy I do I think that we
may be working on those capabilities but
they won't necessarily represent an
existential threat I I I think what I'm
saying is they indicate the beginning of
a trajectory towards a greater threat
right at inflection we're actually not
working on either of those capabilities
recursive self-improvement and autonomy
and I've chosen a product Direction
which I think can enable us to be
extremely successful without needing to
work on that I mean we're not an AGI
company we're not trying to build a
super intelligence but aside from
autonomy what else might AGI or super
intelligence entail well how about
matching or exceeding the problem
solving ability of the best human
mathematicians within a decade wait
scrap that 2026 Terren ta who I believe
is recorded as the highest IQ human
around said this when integrated with
tools I expect say a 2026 level AI when
used properly will be a trustworthy
co-author in mathematical research and
in many other fields as well what else
well how about self-improving capabil
abilities this is from the AI power
Paradox in foreign affairs soon AI
developers will likely succeed in
creating systems with self-improving
capabilities a critical juncture in the
trajectory of this technology that
should give everyone pause open AI
agrees saying it's possible that AGI
capable enough to accelerate its own
progress could cause major changes to
happen surprisingly quickly and back to
sullon in foreign affairs with each new
order of magnitude unexpected
capabilities emerge few predicted that
training on Raw text would enable large
language models to produce coherent
novel and even creative sentences few
are still expected language models to be
able to compose music or solve
scientific problems as some now can an
order of magnitude don't forget means
being 10 times bigger but how about a
thousand times bigger than GPT 4 in 3
years right so if everybody gets that
power that starts to look like you know
individuals having the power of
organizations or even States I'm talking
about models that are like two or three
orders of magnitude maybe four orders of
magnitude on from where we are and we're
not far away from that we're going to be
training models that are 1,000x larger
than they currently are in the next 3
years even at inflection with the
compute that we have will be 100x larger
than the current Frontier models in the
next 18 months you can start to see why
AGI means so much more than just a
chatbot and here's another example this
again came from solon's book released 2
days ago he talks about the one a cry
Ransom whereare attack that caused
billions of dollars of damage back in
2017 and he said imagine oneoc cry being
able to patch its own vulnerabilities
learning to detect and stop further
attempts to shut it down a weapon like
this is on the horizon if not already in
development let's move on though from
sullon to Demis hassabis head of Google
Deep Mind and this article yesterday in
Time Magazine which was fascinating
apparently hbus warned Elon Musk about
the the risks from artificial
intelligence back in 2012 saying that
machines could become super intelligent
and surpass as mere mortals maybe that's
why he's glad that chat GPT moved the
Overton window the window of what it's
permissible to discuss in public in 2012
it was probably embarrassing to talk
about artificial intelligence let alone
AGI we also learned that musk tried to
stop deep mind being sold to Google musk
put together financing to stop the deal
and had an hourong Skype call with
hassabis saying the future of AI should
not be controlled by Larry that's Larry
Page one of the co-founders of Google
obviously that didn't happen and we are
soon set to see Gemini from Google deep
mind that's their rival to gp4 I've got
a whole video series on it so do check
that out but the Revelation from today
was that hassabis said this Gemini
represents a combination of scaling and
Innovation it's very promising early
results and as a Londoner like me
hassabis will be prone to understatement
so a British person saying very
promising early results means it might
shock a few people now you remember from
earlier in the video where I quoted
ultman back in 2015 saying this AI is
about making humans better not a single
entity that is a million times more
powerful well for musk who remember
co-founded open AI that was apparently
the vision behind neuralink that's his
attempt to tie the Bots closer to humans
making them an extension of the will of
individuals rather than systems that
could go Rogue and develop their own
goals and intentions another idea for
musk would be to build a sustainable
human Colony on Mars before anything
went wrong speaking of going wrong we
also have this from Demis hassabis in
Time Magazine he was asked are there any
capabilities that if Gemini remember
that's their version of GPT 4 or 5
exhibited them in your testing phase
you'd decide no we cannot release this
he said yeah I mean it's probably
several generation ations down the line
and then for anyone who's watched my
smart GPT series they'd know that I
would agree with the next part I think
the most pressing thing that needs to
happen in the research area of AI is to
come up with the right evaluation
benchmarks for capabilities because we'd
all love a set of maybe even hundreds of
tests where if your system passed it
that could get a kite Mark and you'd say
right this is safe to deploy the problem
is we don't have those types of
benchmarks currently for example is this
system capable of ction can it replicate
itself across data centers this is the
kind of level we're talking about these
are the sorts of things you might want
to test for but we need practical
pragmatic tests for them I think that's
the most pressing thing for the field to
do as a whole our current evals and
benchmarks are just not up to the task
apparently we have plenty of time to do
this at least according to sullon who
don't forget along with hassabis was the
co-founder of Deep Mind many of us more
or less expected we're more or less sure
was coming which was there'd be a
breakthrough at some company like deep
mind where we would you know the the
people building the technology would
recognize that they had finally gotten
into the end zone or close enough to it
so that they're now in the presence of
something that's fundamentally different
than anything that's come before and
there'd be this question okay is this
safe to work with safe to create an API
for the idea was that that you'd have
this digital orle you know in in a box
you know would already have been air
gapped from the internet and incapable
of doing anything until we let it out
and then the question would be have we
have we done enough safety testing to
let it out but now it's pretty clear
that everything is already more or less
out and we're building our most powerful
models already in the wild they're open-
Source versions of the next best model
and is containment even a dream at this
point it's definitely not too late we're
a long long way away this is really just
the beginning uh you know we we have
plenty of time to address this the more
that these models and these ideas happen
in the open the more they can be
scrutinized and they can be pressure
tested and held accountable so I think
it's great that they're happening in
open source at the moment we have to be
humble about the Practical reality about
how these things emerge the initial
framing that it was going to be possible
to invent this Oracle AI that stays in a
box and we'll just probe it and poke it
and test it until we can prove that it's
going to be safe that we'll stay in the
bunker and keep it hidden from everybody
I mean this is a complete nonsense and
it's attached to the super intelligence
framing it was just a completely wrong
metaphor he might want to tell that to
hassabis who said this recently if a
system didn't pass the evals that means
you wouldn't release it until you sorted
that out and perhaps you would do that
in something like a hardened simulator
or hardened sandbox with cyber security
things around it so these are the types
of ideas we have but they need to be
made a little bit more concrete I think
that's the most pressing thing to be
done in time for those types of systems
when they arrive and here's the key
moment because I think we've got a
couple of years probably or more that's
not actually a lot of time if you think
about the research that has to be done I
think I am much closer to hassabis than
sullon on this one personally I'd love a
button where you could click at the
exact moment where you want want AI to
stop for me that would be after it cures
Alzheimer's but before it creates rabies
2.0 it would be after it solves
mathematics but before it gets too good
at Warfare maybe such a button could be
devised at Bletchley Park in November
which was the place where the Enigma was
cracked in World War II they are being
advised by some of the top mines in AI
so there is a chance and apparently they
want 10 times as many people to join
them in the next few weeks but anyway at
the very least I hope I've persuaded you
that AGI is going to mean a lot more
than just clever chat Bots thank you so
much for watching to the end and have a
wonderful day